you're not seeing this pink not properly
this camera can't capture YouTube can't
store it and your screen can't display
it I mean the studio of artist Stuart
Semple and he's made what he calls the
pinkest pink I've been painting since I
was five years old and I've seen a lot
of pink and thousands and thousands of
people have used the pink and nobody
said they've seen a pink a pink this
stuff's really pink I've created the
pink is pink at the greenest green the
loveliest blue and the yellow is yellow
I've also created the world's most
glittery natural glitter and the maddest
blackest art material in the world about
a year year and a half ago a company
called Surrey nanosystems announced that
they created vantablack which was this
really awesome blacker than the blackest
black black but they gave the exclusive
rights to an artist called Hanish Kapoor
to use it and that annoyed a lot of
artists and I got really annoyed as well
so I put my pink his pink out on the
website I put a disclaimer that you
weren't an issue Kapoor you weren't
associated with Annika bought a lot of
people that was quite funny and a lot of
people bought the pink
unfortunately including Anna Kapoor he
managed to get his hands on it and then
he dipped his finger in it and put it on
Instagram that he'd got the pink it was
sort of gray and sort of really
frustrating when he did that because all
of a sudden we were getting thousands
and thousands of orders we ended up
staying up for about four weeks making
pink pain and nothing else could happen
and it just took over our whole life
there are all sorts of complicated and
clever ways that computers can store
colour but by the time this video
reaches your screen it's basically just
a series of numbers that say how bright
to make each of the red green and blue
pixels they're you know the tiny lights
that make up your screen and unless
you've got a really fancy expensive
screen those numbers run from 0 to 255
which is eight ones in binary zero means
turn the pixel off 255 means as bright
as it can go
that means your screen can show
somewhere around 16 million colors but
that's not every color and it's not this
one because if I pointed this camera at
the Sun you wouldn't be blinded the
numbers can't go above
255 I can't make your screen go brighter
than 100% but if a point something
extremely dark the number can't go below
zero I can't make your screen any darker
than if it was turned off in the same
way there are colors that are so intense
your screen can't display when the
pixels cannot go red green or blue
enough and this is one of them there are
massive libraries of pigments organic
ones inorganic one synthetic ones
created ones natural ones and they've
been digging them up since day dot you
know mummy brown was made out of
ground-up mummies so there's a huge
database of pigments that you can order
and you can play with them I've made
mixes of these pigments and binders
created something tweaked it and gone
back and what these relationships right
so it's quite in a complicated little
potion actually in a few years time
technology will move on it's already
possible to buy expensive equipment to
with a wider color gamut and that might
be able to display this pink but in the
meantime I can try and simulate what
being here is like in this shot this one
here I have digitally adjusted the
saturation of this pink so it's not
quite as intense now if I turn it back
up imagine that change but more so
that's help ink this pink is it is
ridiculously pink thank you just feel at
sample and all the team at his workshop
pull down the description for more about
them their pigment and this pink this is
gorgeous
I cannot get over how luminous this is I
start down it's like well this isn't
doing anything this is this is just
powder and then it just goes